just checking over your new hire forms
American citizen nice no dependents me
neither unless you count my birds
just doesn't say anywhere on here if
you've got a girlfriend
I didn't is there space for that there's
this section here is there anything else
we should know some people like to
volunteer it oh um then also no no no
okay well I will just jot that down then
but you are heterosexual right is are
you allowed to ask that
no
just listen up I've got an important
announcement this is your garden variety
generic decongestant and this is crystal
meth okay the Tweakers use this to make
this so stop selling them this so they
can't make this that guy told me he had
a really bad cold he was buying 35 boxes
Cheyenne that should have been a red
flag okay here's your Noggin let's thank
Dina for that helpful tip of the day
thank you Dina mom the only one that
thinks it's weird that she walking
around with a bad crystal meth now I
used to in these meetings with some
wisdom from the good book but then
someone reported me to corporate heck
yeah I did look I'm a Christian too but
in these four walls my Bible is the
employee code of conduct we all thank
you for it yeah you're welcome
pray for you Dina pray for you too I'm
praying right now it's so hard
okay stay still I don't usually wear
eyeliner Sharpie occasionally so tell me
about this special guy okay male
caucasian no discernible scars or
tattoos
sound streamy yeah you know speaking of
boys I've got a pretty big decision to
make my boyfriend he um I'm glad we
could bond like this
thank you
oh she's here
hey here's the deal reporter you're in
my house now you see those security
cameras I will have eyes on you at all
times
I got it oh
you can all go back to work
um unless anyone wants to file an
official Complaint of racial bias
Sandra I often feel uncomfortable in the
stock room there's a man there Sal who
makes comments about my breasts yeah
okay what you're talking about is sexual
harassment that's a whole other video
okay it's just that sometimes he calls
me at home yeah we're not gonna watch
another video Sandra
sorry Jonah I'd prefer if you didn't
offer to shuttle our employees to the
abortion clinic no I meant rides in
general what if it was just for a pap
smear could I get a ride for that they
recommend one a year but I like to go
extra make sure everything's
up to code okay I'm just gonna say it
I'm fine with you driving your
co-workers anywhere except the abortion
clinic damn it Glenn you cannot talk
about your personal feelings on abortion
in the workplace I didn't bring up
abortions
abortion abortion abortion abortion
abortion she dug your own grave
okay
I've got a shoplifter in the girl's ears
oh I'm taking four breaks today so I
guess we both got stuff to brag about
it
[Music]
gorgeous piece of garbage I'm a Hunter
some people like to hunt elk or deer eye
on people
and your head is going on my wall
I didn't steal anything oh you didn't
well this was easy sorry for the mix-up
you can go here let me get you your
purse
well well well look at what we got here
that's mine I came in with it how
convenient for you well oh
is my word against yours then
if only I had some sort of device right
at my fingertips that had recorded your
illegal activity oh
if only I could simply press a button
and see that recording oh
[Music]
[Applause]
if only that it worked
hey uh Dina I'm in a hurry if you want
to talk you have to walk with me oh okay
this is gonna sound crazy but do you
remember your first period because
February 4th 2003 it was a Tuesday
unseasonably warm okay so I was 19. late
bloomer but I've more than made up for
that since my gyno says I ovulate like a
champ I drop eggs hard all right you
know my aunt was warm with two vaginas
yeah she always thought it would help
her date but it didn't she died alone
well she will die alone she's still
alive she's only like 50 or something
okay thanks
I think I got all the information I need
very convincing
what do you mean dear what I mean dear
is if you just stayed in Pharmacy I
wouldn't have added an eye but no one
your age is throwing their money away on
a new bed I mean let's be honest how
many years of sleeping do you even have
left I don't know what's happening here
well I'll tell you what's happening your
cover's been blown sweetheart
hello Chicago I'm not stupid ma'am I
have the arm strength of a chimp but
there is just too much real estate back
here I'd have to dislocate your shoulder
do it
okay but you'll have to teach one of
your bridesmaids to do this on the day
if you're hungry that can of beans is up
for grabs but uh not this one I'm good
do you mind if I turn on the where's
your radio oh I special ordered my truck
without one yeah it costs a little extra
but it makes the vehicle less appealing
to thieves because no one wants a truck
without a radio
name a song though I'll sing it for you
okay no no go ahead I got a photographic
memory for music okay
um
Single Ladies not familiar with that one
Uptown Funk don't know it Dancing Queen
nope Thriller
Michael Jackson
you can't name a song by some guy you
went to middle school with it has to be
popular
Oh Danny Boy the pipes the pipes
I don't know if just randomly driving
around is a good idea
where do teenagers go
prom is there a prom around no I just
meant that we should think like a
teenager
hey Mom get out of my room
you don't understand my generation
pimples
it's not helping
oh wait wait wait wait is that him hey
hey stop it's him it's him
that's one of our cards that's one of
our cars who cares
doing
[Music]
who cares I care hey that is Cloud Nine
Star Property
[Music]
you know one second thought I don't
think that is one of our cards
so what are we thinking for lunch
sandwiches burritos Indian Tapas what is
up with you do you even want to find Bo
yes of course I do
maybe not right away
I'm really not anxious to get back to
the wedding day sale okay
seeing all those women celebrating
having found someone
I'm not getting any younger kind of a
bummer well it can be hard to date if
you'd seen some of the guys I dated
gay racist mean redhead
that was all one guy oh I've dated some
losers
I dated this one guy who would only
speak in Monty Python quotes the last
guy I dated only hung out with me to
play chess with my dad and the guy
before that was just using me for my
freezer I dated three guys who were
dating me just to get close to my friend
Renee and Renee wasn't even that hot
whatever this is not about Renee
well Renee sounds like a sack of crap
she was
thank you I just call it like I see it
yes
there is a
guy at work that things have been
getting pretty intense with
really whoo well I don't want to talk
about my personal life with co-workers
but I will say that there has been some
very heavy flirtation happening I've
been changing my shirt multiple times a
day just because of all the pet stains
steamy stuff should probably go back
to help the brides have cleared out
you know no one's Really Gonna notice if
we're gone another hour or two
well what would we do
um oh we could pamper ourselves
oh yeah
this place is way fancier than my usual
spot
boy style let's wipe up the gunpowder
man I feel like a princess